hello everyone and welcome to rational
science directly from frankfurt germany
right yep
and uh what do we do here well we do a
little bit of physics okay
and probably the only place uh the only
site on the internet that does physics
because everybody else does a lot of
math they use all these concepts such as
field and wave and ether and whatever
and they move all these concepts around
here we only move objects hello everyone
and welcome to rational science directly
from frankfurt germany
and uh what do we do here well we do a
little bit of physics okay and uh yeah
and probably the only place uh the only
site on the internet that does
because everybody else does a lot of
math they use all these concepts such as
field and wave and objects ether and
whatever and they move all these
concepts around
here we only move objects hello everyone
and welcome to rational science directly
from franklin germany
right now
and uh what do we do here well we do a
little bit of physics okay
and probably the only place uh the only
site on the internet that does
because everybody else does a lot of
math they use all these concepts such as
field and wave and objects ether and
whatever and they pull these concepts
around
here we only move objects hello everyone
and welcome to rational science directly
from germany
because everybody else does a lot of
math they use all these concepts such as
field and wave and
ether and whatever the name of these
concepts around
here we only do objects hello everyone
and welcome to rational science directly
from germany
[Music]
because everybody else does a lot of
math they keep talking hello can you
hear me
see if it's any better any better now uh
let me know if we're doing better now
i don't know why we're getting an echo
why would we get an echo this turned off
these concepts hello hello can everybody
hear us
is the echo still persisting
that's better
okay so apparently uh
yeah good now
okay
where were you uh where were we
well uh
yeah we had to turn something off that
we had running in the background there
low budget
low budget production
okay but anyways we do physics here and
what we need to figure out in physics if
we're going to do a physical
interpretation is what the invisible
entities that mother nature father
universe
god the devil whoever out there uses to
do stuff like gravity magnetism
light etc
and you can't do it with concepts and
that's what we have out there we have
mathematical physics
so-called physics that's with quotations
does it with uh concepts they they reify
concepts and that's what they move
around now they reify objects
uh well no they really mean to turn
concept into an object but the issue is
that you know you don't get a physical
interpretation
and when you put them against the wall
they say well that's philosophy anyway
or it was a metaphor yeah it was just an
approximation it's just so you kind of
understand it but then you nail them to
the wall it's like oh no it's not what
we really meant
okay but uh we're gonna start
yeah yeah yeah it is uh we're gonna
start with extinction extinction of man
and that is a branch of physics by the
way you know it's paleontology
but um it has to do with actual
man isn't it well yeah
already
that's not the past
well yeah
even if you talk because the theory
theory is always about the past and
you're trying to figure out how animals
in the past died how plants in the past
died and you have to have a mechanism
for that and that falls under physics
mechanisms fall under physics
okay so we start there and we have all
subjects related to that i've got some
headlines all of them more or less to do
with uh the situation in the world today
and i'm gonna start with uh uh something
that's down my alley just for the sake
of it here and it's uh these two
uh a couple that sold secrets or tried
to sell secrets
and they were selling it to an fbi agent
undercover agent
and so the question is whether uh in the
world of today it makes any sense to be
a spy
or if it ever made any sense to me
okay so it's something that you may want
to consider
and uh the only thing i'm to tell you
about this is that
uh comes to mind is you have people like
assange and ed snowden and they work for
the us government these are u.s
government operations there's a movie of
snowden on netflix now i don't doubt it
perfectly i saw that i'm like oh my god
dude yeah
they're making them into heroes you know
but the issue is that uh one of the
things that happens is when you have an
asset like that out there
um sometimes you have to sacrifice it
and so what uh snowden and
assange may find out in the end
maybe you know is that at some point for
some reason for whatever reason the way
things turn out
they might actually have to sacrifice
them at the last moment and say buddy
now we're going to make you for real
we're going to say that you were a spy
as you were working for the for the
competition or whatever
okay another issue related to
uh some of the things that are going on
in the world uh it always falls on the
other side why don't you just put it
between the two things at the top
well yeah
anyways uh is uh the taliban they are
asking a lot of them are asking now why
did we fight
you know you have all these guerrilla
movements like um uh in cuba in the 1959
fidel castro now you have these guys uh
in afghanistan and a lot of these folks
after they conquer power once they're up
there now they have to rule and then
they find that that's a lot more
difficult than doing the revolution that
was fun you know
risking your life getting a gun killing
someone that was great yeah that was
adventure that was great now you got to
sit down at a desk and do bureaucracy
and yeah and do some bureaucratic stuff
and the question is you know that's a
lot harder to do
and right now the taliban are are you
know uh they say
the article is saying there that there's
a few guys at the top they're doing
quite well and all the soldiers the guys
at the bottom they're not doing as well
and they say why did we fight why is
this what we fought for
well they're not really made for that i
guess soldiers aren't really
you know being a soldier doesn't make
you a good leader i guess
being a good soldier doesn't make you an
economist yeah exactly for example you
got to run the economy of a country okay
and one of the questions there is uh do
we have the right leaders in the world
to do economics for the world you know
in every country of the world that's one
of the things you gotta put in in your
mind see uh in in many countries you
have this democratic system where they
vote for
a uh politician and he becomes the prime
minister the president whatever the head
of the country and the question is
is that the right guy does he know or he
or or is this just a guy that's up there
who was lucky or whatever got enough
money convinced people to vote for him
he's up there does this mean he's really
qualified to take decisions on the
economy of that country i mean the next
question would be is anyone
well some people some are better than
others right that's my point
and you might not be selecting the top
guy maybe
so democracy does not really guarantee
that you get the qualified guy up there
neither does a revolution like the
taliban's there
okay it does huh what does nothing does
uh
there was an answer to that
there is no magical uh there's no
magical button no no give me the right
guy
okay and then we have another situation
we talked about taiwan being
a focal point in the east
and here's another focal point we call
it the east but it's east europe
and eastern europe and it's that the
united states wants to incorporate both
um georgia a country that used to belong
to the soviet union as a province and uh
ukraine they would incorporate them into
nato the military alliance of the west
and russia says that if they do that
they the the west is overstepping uh
it's stepping across a red line a line
that they don't want them to cross
because if they do there's gonna be war
and so we have two situations now we
have one in eastern europe which is
ukraine and georgia
uh and then we have taiwan in the east
are these going to be the
start of world war three
you know this is something you got to
think about
uh especially for this generation you
know
um
will will there be a world war three and
if there is a world war three
uh will it involve this uh these two
these regions that we know very little
we don't even know where they are on the
map you know it's like that uh we have
taiwan on one end and we have ukraine
and georgia and the other well one thing
about world war three is that people
have gotten pretty used to peace at
least in first world countries so they
kind of take peace for granted they
can't say ah war never happened again
that's that's a thing of the past
yeah not that it really articulates it
as such but it's kind of like that feel
like no one really thinks about war
but you know um
if if nobody thinks about war but except
the military the military of every
country
they're investing yeah that's their job
and so they're investing in armaments
and preparing the troops and all that
stuff
they go on maneuvers uh there's a lot
going on out there that the common folk
are not even aware of you know
most of us we just punch our cards every
day and that's it but uh
he's going to deal with the german
military is doing
something someone asked me german
military what is that
if there even is one i know there's the
bundesliga
yeah what are they doing i don't know
no idea because it doesn't concern me in
a way but i think the same applies to
most people that that aren't like in a
military family or have military ties
they don't really it's not a part of
their world
yeah
but uh one of the things that you got to
consider is the possibility of world war
three and maybe we're due for a world
war because remember we had world war
one then what was it like 20 years later
we had world war ii
it's you know it's been a long time we
need another war guys you know let's do
something about that
okay one of the issues that i brought up
was this uh thing about uh women
matching men lots of comments on that
and uh we had a little bit of discussion
today here with uh odds and i beat him
up guys
i got him yeah i'm not throwing anything
down anybody's throat i'm asking
questions that's all i'm doing and some
people say
did your wife make you say that
no no the issue here is i'm asking i
don't know the answer i'm asking the
questions around here
i'm just asking okay and what's the
question well here here you see the uh
one guy put a note there says a female
uh would not be ranked 11th in a male
sport but rather wouldn't even make the
top 6
uh and we're talking about maybe sports
like you know rough sports like
wrestling and
uh you know fighting and so on of any
kind and so the guy gives us an example
the running again which i gave the other
day it says for example the women's
world record in 100 meter sprint is
10.49 seconds right this record by
florence griffin okay
has stood since 1988 has never been
seriously challenged by a female okay
and uh so he says that uh even high
school running boys can beat her
and uh i'm not sure if that's true
here's the other side of that coin okay
if you're interested
if i can get it up here
oh that's what it was okay
i wanted to put it here that's what it
was okay so here you see uh the ranking
uh florence uh would come in third if
she ran in 1936.
okay and uh the 100 meter dash was
won by jesse owens and he had a 10.3 and
he was the world champion at the time
okay now you might say well bill you're
comparing apples and oranges yeah maybe
i am my point here is that women have
come up the the ranks and you can see
they're two of the
top runners
of today contemporary days and they
would come up in third and fifth place
in that race so they have come up to
speed over the years they would have
beaten those last three guys there okay
because they were at 10.6 so i'm not
sure how many boys in dallas texas would
beat these women okay
uh that's uh that's easy to say but hard
to do okay uh these women run fast i'm
not saying they're
they're they would beat all men but
they've come up the ranks and the
question is if we give them enough time
another hundred years
will uh women run as fast as men and one
of the issues i raised with anse today
is you know you have a height difference
like if you take uh saint bolt you know
he's probably taller than griff's joyner
but if you get a woman that
you know just an example okay
don't beat me up on this that has the
same height the same leg
spread
good muscles in the legs well maybe she
can run just as fast as
uh bolt maybe i don't know i mean give
it another 100 years
and
maybe we progress to the point where
women catch up and one of the issues
there is also this dimorphism right now
if you take uh heights of women and men
in the world well there's you're gonna
see a difference men in general
are taller than women
given enough time will that dimorphism
disappear
and again i'm asking a question
people say well what are you saying yeah
i'm just asking you a question will it
disappear how dare you how dare i dare
you
are you a feminist person
no no i'm just uh putting my
finger in your in your wound you know i
want to make sure people think about
these things you know will women catch
up uh we'll dive
one of the things you got to look at is
you know in among the primates uh you
have um
for example the um
gorillas
the guerrilla male is much bigger than
the female gorilla
but remember these are monkeys that are
in the wild they're in the hunter
gathering stage okay
we evolved from there and we are the
ones the the monkeys with the least uh
dimorphism uh among all all these uh
apes
and so the question is is that because
you know we went from uh hunter
gathering to being military to you know
we used to do all the wars women stayed
at home
and today we're all in the office and so
there's not that much competition
from a physical point of view we don't
do that much heavy lifting right
compared to gorillas how will that
evolve
and then
another
bit of information you may want to keep
in mind is that
uh you know women
live longer than men
is that hardwired into our species that
females have to live longer than men
have to
the way you say it you sound old but
like you're waiting for that oh my god
they have to live the 110 i feel bad for
them
yeah
on the average women live longer is that
hardwired or
is that something
men can catch up with women given enough
time well i guess the question is more
do they have the potential for longer
life because obviously run over
in other words
which one of these uh
categories whatever you are called
are we hardwired which ones have we
learned over time which ones can we
overcome these are the question you know
and these are just questions i ask
questions i don't answer them
okay
uh along the same line
says
ah come on why am i having so many
problems with this today
yeah but
okay uh what is the mechanism by which
inbreeding causes garbage stuck uh stock
uh children
yeah because the issue is did the royal
family have hemophilia because they were
inbred or because they happen to have
hemophilia allele okay would the
inbreeding have
caused hemophilia if neither parent had
that allele
in conservation biology there is a
phenomenon where a population with low
genetic diversity and the associated
problems
can overcome these problems without
increasing their genetic diversity okay
it simply requires that the frequency of
healthy alleles in increase is increased
and that the defective alleles are bred
out
uh my answer is you know i'm not i'm not
a specialist in all this stuff all i can
tell you is that
history has shown to me
at least to me you know for whatever
reason magic you want to call it
whatever that inbreeding
leads to uh bad
dna in other words the the kids that are
born after two three generations of
inbreeding turn out bad for one reason
or another they could be mentally or
physically handicapped in some way after
several generations and i don't know if
that's the reason that in the past they
decided that
sisters can't marry brothers or brothers
or sons can't marry mothers and so on
maybe at some point humans realize that
that caused a problem
and so they stopped that but at one
point we you know it was a
free-for-all everybody can sleep with
everybody and we stopped that a long
time ago in the names of the caves
and
today if we
continue inbreeding for example if you
uh marry your sister you're a guy you
marry your sister you have a kid and you
have several kids now they marry among
them they have kids and they marry among
them
how long can we keep that up to the
point where you know we start having
some physical or mental problems and i'm
saying that you can't continue doing
that
but that is what the human race has been
doing for 200 000 years and that's been
accentuated in the last 200 years
because that's when the population
increased exponentially
so i'm saying that you know um you can't
keep in breeding now what the mechanism
is as far as you know the alleles i
can't tell you i'm not an expert on that
why would an exponential rise in global
population make inbreeding
genetic problems worse
uh i'm not sure about why it would but
all i'm saying is it seems like here we
we can't we're eight billion people
today when i was born we were two and a
half billion so what did you do
population
tripled since i was born okay and on the
earth
and that population doubled from the uh
even more than doubled since the about
1820 when we reached a billion that's a
calculation they made and that
population of 1 billion came from the
300 million at the beginning of the
christian era
so you know you you see this progression
and you know first of all you have these
founder effects and population
bottlenecks that chop off part of
humanity you know through disease wars
whatever people who don't reproduce so
we don't come from the 300 million we
come from a portion of those 300 million
and from the 1 billion in the 19th
century we come from a portion of that 1
billion and so on down the line so we're
always a percentage we come from a
percentage
of
the people in the past
and so all i can say is that you know
through these uh population bottlenecks
which is usually
related to diseases it chops off
humanity all those people who do not
have natural defenses
so
what you can be sure of today is that if
you have defenses today it's because our
grandfather's great grandfather whatever
they had
the right stock to pass certain diseases
while others who did not they fell
behind they kind of slept on that cove
defense though
you can't hit him
we had aids and so on we don't have
natural defenses
did they invent covid to give us a new
infection to fight off
that's some deep [ __ ] someone's
listening i help
you so you're saying that uh they did
this in the lab
that's what i'm saying like what if they
listen to you and they're like oh bill's
saying the new species or
or to to
to to
what he says improve genetic diversity
we need new illnesses that we haven't
yet fought so we have to make them well
one guy there in fact i think one of the
comments there is that in fact this was
create not not only covet but in general
the the people who rule they want to
chop off some of humanity off because
we're too many people already we're 8
billion people or close to that and that
number of people where the resources we
have on earth is unsustainable that's
the argument who would watch
which which high up would want to do
that in their own backyard
like if we're going to cut off a whole
bunch of people and i'm let's say i'm
the chinese overlord person why would i
throw it in china why not in someone
else's backyard
well remember every country has its own
problems and so if you see too many
people in one country you might say well
i gotta chop off half of the indian
population in india you know and
i don't know or maybe it's the other way
around maybe the enemy says i'll i'll do
it for you don't worry are they trained
yeah hey guys we need a war so we can
let's help each other out cut each other
cut our population down but but you know
my argue my argument is if you cut
population down let's say we we get rid
of a billion people any way you want uh
disease war whatever it doesn't matter
you chop off one billion people
so instead of eight billion where seven
billion or six billion or five billion
you keep chopping up billions all you're
doing is reducing
uh demand now you have less demand and i
think what's going to happen is you're
going to have a lot of these uh
um
the opposite effect the economy is going
to fall to peace what you do is you look
for the people who aren't buying
anything anymore and you kill them
that's how you do it because then you
kill off the people who are who aren't
adding to the demand can you delete
three billion people from earth and
still have demand you kill the people
who already don't have demand is what
i'm saying yeah okay but even if you do
that i mean uh
[Laughter]
you you get a voice you you remove the
people who don't purchase or whatever
okay so somebody else let's see that
definition one billion people
you get rid of a billion people uh
can you live with the remaining
remaining people because a lot of those
people are maybe workers or whatever so
yeah but exactly we have too many old
people china us to benefit from getting
rid of hey hey i'm not old i'm like that
like 20 years old
okay let's continue here along the same
lines uh with uh oh my
it fall off to god other side
give me a second here guys
got it there okay
uh
oh here it is this guy says is it
possible that a control reduction in
population might be accomplished when uh
taking the global economic into
economics into consideration kill off
all the non-productive rebellious
people and keep all the mindless workers
it might be mindful okay the uh economic
instabilities might be another reason
for them to kill off a certain talking
about the new world order people or the
people who rule
the uh economic inabilities might be
another reason for them to kill off a
certain amount of the population all the
while ushering in a global workforce
program uh less creditors means less
debtors need to pay off okay
so uh yeah should
if we get rid of half the population in
the world for example you know just an
example uh is that good for us
or will that kill our economy i mean
this amounts to kill off all the people
who are bad for the economy right
well uh
how do you tell in eight billion people
who's good or who's bad i mean if you
i'm obviously i'm just giving an example
we chop off four billion people let's
call them the old people we chop off
anyone over 60. that's me
uh or whatever over 70 any agent make a
number yeah pick a number
anything about that we kill like
logan's run right and so the question is
are we
killing the economy by doing that
because yeah we got rid of the people
who consume resources but at the same
time you know that consumption is what
drives the economy so it's like shooting
yourself in the foot
that's the way i look at it at least
anyways i don't think you can get rid of
uh of course you'd say that you're 68 or
something
you're you're trying to save yourself
i'm already 20 years old
oh my god come on bob
you put it at the top there doesn't work
here okay uh one guy says uh wrote to me
and says i solve the money problem no
crypto [ __ ] no shiny yellow rocks a
completely new form of physical cash a
simple yet powerful idea uh what can i
say about this i'm saying that um
this is not an issue of um
of creating new money
you can you can replace green money with
brown money we haven't solved the
problem the issue is if we have no jobs
and right now we're creating a lot of
jobs in the internet business in the
internet world and we're not creating
jobs where it counts which is in
manufacturing and agriculture where you
produce something useful when you when
you have real growth but when you
produce when you have services any kind
of services for that matter but
primarily within services the services
in the uh
in the internet business what are you
creating you know one guy saying the
other guy pays them what have we done
what have we what has increased in in
growth
in economic growth happiness and yeah
that's what people say it's just
entertainment
the only time it turns into growth is
when that uh money is circulated and
goes into producing something like roads
houses
uh cars
uh tangible things until you produce
something tangible such as that what
have you built oh you did you know one
guy sings and and that song went away it
was uh two seconds of uh pleasure why is
the tangent why is tangibility the
deciding factor of usefulness because
i'm saying i'm a growth
i'm saying here's god you know up there
in the sky and you're next to him and
you're looking down on earth what do you
see well if you if you look at some in
american indians in the 19th century
they had a bunch of teepees
no roads you know some buffalo out there
you know and you look there and you say
what what is there
how can i tell by looking
how advanced that civilization is now
look at the same
area
21st century we're looking down at new
york city and you see skyscrapers and so
on well if you compare those two
scenarios one with skyscrapers the other
one with teepees you say well here
here's there's growth there's there's
there's been some economic uh
development over here you know what has
there been nothing you can tell just by
looking
and what are you staring at you're
looking at real things you're not
looking at the songs they made you're
not looking at the dances they made none
of that you're just looking at what they
have
the real things that's the way i look at
it so how do you tell that a country has
growth or has growth that has grown
economically by looking from the from
the sky and saying what have they built
you look at germany and you take any
country in africa and i'm sure if you
look at compare those from the sky you
say well germany is more advanced a more
advanced nation and they have a better
standard of living and again we're we're
not saying that they're happier or
anything like that we're just saying it
has a greater standard of living simply
by the construction that you see from
the sky that's what i'm saying what are
you looking at real things you're not
looking at the songs you're not looking
at the haircuts
all the you know actors and the internet
all that stuff is bs
that's the way i look at it yes though
maybe
it's way more complicated good i think
good that's a yes
that's
that's that that's a two hour discussion
right now that's why i'm quiet
okay
uh take a rain check on that
okay uh final issue says do you have an
idea on what's the next dominant species
will be after uh
everybody says the cockroach if i think
if you ask that question to a million
people
everybody would say the cockroaches
they'll survive is it the cockroaches
or will the cockroaches come down with
us we'll we'll be eating cockroaches at
the last moment we try to kill him now
and we can't kill him
yes we can no
if we all why don't we all join together
to kill the cockroaches and mosquitos
because we can't
yeah maybe no one wants to see those
dudes if they went extinct it wouldn't
be like the lions or it was like oh the
lions are going sting if someone said
the cockroaches extinct is going extinct
everybody like good
okay let me turn that thought around for
you let me turn it around in the
carboniferous era okay in the carbon
first era there were tons of insects
and that's what a lot of the amphibians
ate they had you know these dragon files
with
dragonflies with uh you know uh
two meter long wings you know flying
around they were airplanes tiny
airplanes uh they're no longer around
and so the question is hold it these
dragonflies they were there i mean i'm
just mentioning one animal right uh they
were flying all around and they they
filled the skies etc i mean i don't know
how many there were and probably tons of
them and today they're not around so
something happened to them and the
question plays huh
yeah but not those not those monsters
though those would pull you up
they shrunk a bit as well yeah they
struck me we have a different type of
dragon flyers today but this is the
issue a lot of the insects that existed
you know in the past even in the
cretaceous in the jurassic etc there
were insects all around where are they
now
you know what happened to them uh
remember there were different plants
also in those days so uh you know you
have one insect eating another insect
whatever you know there was a
herbivorous insect that probably ate
whatever plant was around certainly no
angiosperms because there were no
angiosperms in those days that hadn't
been invented yet so they ate something
else and when those plants went away
well so did the insects and the
amphibians and all these other animals
the whole the whole system collapsed and
so even if the cockroaches survived
okay so they ruled the planet after us
great and they got to learn to eat them
weeds
especially whatever eats the weeds is
gonna yeah
i say the same thing i'm saying that
it's probably gonna be does anything eat
weeds
uh yeah there are insects that uh eats
the weeds uh
stuff that we don't eat you know we uh
we don't need all the angiosperms by the
way the weeds a lot of those are uh you
know uh
they're angiosperms but we don't need
them we don't eat every angiosperm out
there we picked our especially the
grasses that's what we chose we chose
weed corn and so on those are the grass
of the family of the grasses
and so we eat those and there's a lot of
stuff out there that we don't need you
know like cactus not too many i don't
know if anyone eats cactus actually yeah
that's kind that we drink cake that well
it could be yeah i mean but in general
what we what we eat are the grasses and
uh once the grass once we're gone
the grasses are probably gonna be gone
as well you make it sound like cows well
no because they're gonna be taken over
by the weeds that right now we're
fighting the weeds every day we throw
weed killer etc and all these weeds are
getting stronger day by day
holy crap those tomatoes
i feel like where the army of the tomato
without us the freaking weeds can come
in and kill them all yeah probably
okay uh
so let's move on to physics i would do a
quick recap here uh what we did this
month and here you see it i talked about
distance traveled
and i'm saying that distance traveled is
not distance they call it distance but
they're talking about distance traveled
okay and what they're talking about is
something in motion because what do they
do they measure okay
what they're doing is really stretching
the measuring tape okay
and what we're looking at is the end of
the measuring tape
rolling across something whatever
because they need to put a value like 10
meters in an equation they can't put
a qualitative concept like separation in
a in an equation so every time you
listen to distance you better think
distance traveled we're talking about
motion and when you come to think of it
there's no difference between that that
so-called distance which is distance
traveled and displacement position what
is position is position a static concept
that you you know you've got a
like a location absolutely not position
means it's a um
what is it a uh two numbers that you
need to get to to where the treasure
chest is you have an x and y yeah it's a
set of coordinates a um
a an ordered pair or an orbital triplet
or whatever so
all those are synonyms really
because in every single case you're
talking about motion okay and we talked
about velocity what was velocity well
velocity is equal to speed plus
a
um
qualitative concept which is direction
and so you can't have velocity without
direction and so you know the way they
do that they calculate velocity and how
do they do it well they take the
derivative okay they take the derivative
and they end up with this value what is
velocity what is that value it's a
single point in a single
point in time and in space
and what does that mean
it means that that single point has
direction
and how can you have direction on a
single point
what they're doing is uh see if i have
it here
this is what this is what they're
actually doing okay you have to have
smiley pointed in some direction because
other because if you have only the ball
you don't know what direction it's
pointing so it's gonna go so velocity
velocity has that smiley face in some
part of the ball because you have to
know what direction it has but there you
see it at the bottom it's a movie
because you're talking about velocity
which is a dynamic concept but you're
only pulling one point
in the movie one frame of the movie
and so the only way you can get that to
have direction is putting a face to
smiley otherwise you don't have
direction
see the the issue here is that in order
to have direction you need at least two
points okay you need a reference yeah
you need a reference point you need
you need two points to have direction
every concept really has to have
two objects two that's what a concept is
a word that embodies invokes or embodies
two objects and so to have direction you
have to have two points but velocity is
only a single point why because it's a
calculated value okay and so and i
explained that uh in a couple uh
um
lectures ago okay so you can look it up
and you'll see what i said about that
okay anyways that's velocity and then
you have time and that's what we covered
the other day and lots of questions came
up with that a lot of people tried to
define time let's see what they came up
with but first let's find out what i
said i'm saying that time was calculated
from speed they just turned the equation
around and what you have is distance
traveled divided by speed
what are we talking about what is this
then traveled it's motion what is speed
from
qualitative point of view what are we
talking about again we're talking about
motion and so there you have my
definition it's a comparison of two
motions
that's what time is from a
uh so so that you comprehend the notion
what what do we mean when we say time
we're comparing two motions and i gave
the example of the
uh second on the clock compared to the
earth going around the sun and so when
that tick mark
uh when the when the hand goes one tick
mark
the earth went 30 kilometers that was
the original notion today we have the
uh cesium wave you know they look at
that but
originally it was geared to the uh
rolling of the earth around the sun and
what we did we partitioned the year into
days into hours into minutes into
seconds and that's how we came up with
the second originally that's that's
where we have the standard of the second
and then you know again it would have
been pretty silly if we looked up to the
sun and said well the sun moved five
meters so i guess
you know we kind of had to chop it up
into little pieces like how much did the
sun move how much time has passed and
the question is if if the one of the
things you got to think about is the
earth rolling around the sun is that a
perfect
uh
in other words does that vary at all
by one second even uh
we have daylight savings time and stuff
no no no i'm talking about sorry about
the whole thing i'm talking a little
more accuracy here i'm saying over
precision i'm saying
does the earth rolling around the sun
ever change at all by even a fraction of
a second in a million years
does that change or is it always
faithful always rolling around the same
it probably does my bet if if someone
asks me that yes it changes i would
think it's so too but for
the 200 years or 300 years we might be
living you know in a given period of
time it doesn't change that much so it
probably doesn't negligible yeah it's
negligible for for all practical
purposes but the earth around the sun is
one motion what do you say time is two
motions
the earth around the sun is one motion
but i don't have time yet so far we have
motion only the only way
no it's not time that's my point my
point is you need another motion to
compare against that you have to have a
comparison of two motions in order to
have time you need memory but when you
say a year passed yeah that's two
motions
memory
yeah but what do you mean by a year
like if the earth goes around the sun
once yeah this is called an orbit in
physics just that's that's just one
orbit right so far we have nothing but
isn't that one motion
so far we have motion that's one year
isn't that time no a year year has
something else you know you need to
compare it against something like the
seasons or something because all you
have is orbit and you don't have time so
earth goes around the sun once that's
the year which is time no but you can
call it a year so far you have orbit now
don't call it a year yet why not because
here is a time thing
and what do you have for you what do you
mean year what is this year thing all we
have is earthquake
yeah it's a synonym that means year just
means one orbit
yeah
good we don't have time oh we have an
orbit
we have motion
uh circular emotion but we don't have
time in order to have time you have to
have that second or something related to
that you have to have a comparison to
that orbit then you have time otherwise
all you have is motion you know if i
move if i'm the only object in the
universe and uh well you can't even do
it with that because if you have a
single object you don't even have motion
yeah
you need some other object in order to
have motion but then if you have only
two objects one moves with respect to
the other do you have time no i got it
and i'm saying
right now you don't have time all you
have is motion okay you need two motions
a comparison and you need memory
especially time requires absolutely
absolutely requires memory
okay so some people
try to
give us a definition of time here's one
file says if you figure out what motion
is and what it is that is required to
make motion possible you get a better
understanding of what time is aha in
doing so you also independently derive
the special relativity mathematical
equations including the learned
transformation equations
so the issue is whether
we can figure out motion and the cause
of motion and i i'll tell you the answer
that right away okay i i know that by
heart okay so i can tell you what motion
is and and uh how it was created it's
known as god some people say it's the
devil but yeah those are the ones who
said everything in motion
okay there is no or origin to motion
anymore that there is an origin to
matter i mean to say the cause of motion
the cause of motion there is no cause of
motion you're talking about first cause
again well because we our assumption is
that since matter can't become nothing
and nothing can't become matter yeah
then and since there is matter in motion
it always was in motion and always will
be in motion correct and and the issue
is uh you know same for objects for
things for matter you cannot say that
space turned into matter
or that matter can disappear like it
does in mathematical physics and then
turns into nothing whatever nothing we
don't like that yeah so
matter has always been there and will
always be there because it has no way of
turning into space into nothing first of
all second it cannot leave space because
space does not have a border for matter
to cross not even god can escape space
and so matter cannot matter has always
been there and if it's always been there
it's always been in motion you can't say
how did motion start what caused the
startup of motion that's like asking
what caused the beginning of matter you
know
that's only in there in
big bang creationism you have that not
in science in science we don't we laugh
at that you know there is no creation
yeah
it's still weird to think of they're
always there being no beginning to time
right yeah that still blows my mind you
can't do that you can't talk about the
beginning of time or the beginning of
motion or the beginning of matter
it makes no sense
because what would be the mechanism how
would you explain it another file says
we can define our experience of time as
it exists in our heads i guess define it
as our perception and recollection of
continuity
uh of sensory input we're talking about
memory yeah but see again uh what you
have here is
if if you're gonna do it um if you're
gonna define it like that like you know
my perception does that mean that when
you die
time dies for all of us
that's a good question did time die for
us for you only
i think that's a valid question because
if you kill all the observers it's their
time
because there's no memory so you can't
have two points no but i'm talking about
one guy because if i put it under my
experience and i'm saying well for me
time is this
and does that mean that if i die time
dies for all of us because that's how i
define time so you have to define time
in such a way that it's universal that
that it doesn't depend on me dying
that's what i mean but it does bring up
the question of what what role does
consciousness play in time it does
because you need memory
yeah so in that sense yeah even a lion
understands time that's a weird thing to
think about that
we like is there a difference between
time and memory i guess
uh
well you've got to define time in terms
of memory
comparison of two motions i don't think
memory alone
is a synonym of time but you do need
memory as an ingredient of time
that's that's where i looked at it okay
another fellow a lot of people on on the
issue of time by the way
if time was physical
and experience shared we would all slow
d have slow days or fast days uh what we
have is one person telling another my
day went fast and the other
uh
my day was slow okay
yeah again you can't make it in in
a good point
i think time is is relative
if i go to sleep time goes pretty fast
for me that's what einstein
played around with he got into he tied
himself into a not because he says time
is relative motion is relative if you
have six beers time goes pretty slow yes
you can't define time or motion in terms
of an individual in the sense of an
observer because once you do that then
you're in trouble because it does become
subjective in a different way than when
you're comparing two motions when you
say
uh time is two motions
if i die we still have two motions out
there but if i say time depends on my
memory like saying if if i i'm god you
know
if i die time dies well maybe for you
but not for me
so you can't define it in that
subjective way that's my point you gotta
define time in such a way that you can
use it in physics
or understand it from a physical point
of view okay what do we mean by this
word time and i'm saying it's a
comparison of two motions again what did
we see uh you have distance traveled to
define it
divided by uh
speed
and uh what do you have motion divided
by motion it's a comparison of two
motions from a mathematical point of
view by the way
i've just been proven i'm just
converting that into physics i'm saying
what are you talking about motion
divided by motion what are we talking
about qualitatively yeah yeah and it's
motion divided by motion that is the
definition of time that's what we mean
by time do we use time and physics
absolutely not because we have no use
for time what are we going to do with
time what do you what can you explain
with time yeah by saying itself time
but i guess memory if we're because if
we ever use a movie then we're
essentially using memory but we're not
talking about time itself right we kind
of use it but yeah by the background but
we have no use for time itself but you
can use it like maybe
uh something like if you're going to
talk about you don't use it it's just
it's kind of like when you're watching a
movie of a theory
yeah there's time because there's
multiple frames and it's chronological
but you it's like you don't care about
the time itself yeah yeah you could
maybe the only thing like one context i
can imagine is again paleontology if
you're going to compare i don't know the
cambrian against the cretaceous or
whatever then obviously you're talking
about different times this one came
before that one in that sense only do we
need to know that
yeah yeah but do we need to know that
it's 500 million years ago no we do not
[Music]
no but it's also irrelevant if you're
talking about like descendants of
humanity you bring that a lot you talk
about you know exactly when was the
the neanderthal one where the
neanderthals alive were yeah realized
that you kind of want to know which one
came chronologically before the other
but mainly in in that sense it's mainly
an issue i don't care if it's 40 000 or
45 000 years ago what we're looking at
did they live at the same ballpark yeah
you know that's the main point there
okay uh another guy uh all these people
with time okay time is wear and tear
oh yeah that's very poetic
okay i mean we
can't you can see
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh yeah that's very poetic we can't use
that is to try to understand what i mean
we can say time is money that's poetic i
mean i i can't say time is money as a
definition that i'm going to be using to
analyze something in physics or even in
math you know i mean you could but it'll
get shot down
time is money
what do you mean by that yeah
okay another fellow says time is a
measure which is not a thing
yeah but remember the my context there
when i said that
time is treated as a thing by
mathematical physics because they treat
it as a medium they say traveling
through time like if i'm cutting across
cheese you know
then they say
what is gravity it's the warpage of time
and you say gravity warps time you're
always treating time as a physical
object when you give these uh physical
interpretations yeah and that's what
mathematical physics is reinforcing
right yeah yeah and the question is is
that a physical interpretation or is
that poetry yeah you know i mean what
are we talking about is this a closing
argument after you've uh presented your
theory
present your theory first then you can
use all the poetry you want at the end
of your presentation and give us our
close your closing argument in in
singing if you want i don't care but
but when you're when you're giving your
main presentation you can't say oh what
is gravity why doesn't the earth fly out
of the solar system well because we have
this wall of warped time that prevents
it you know you can't go bad for whoever
gets crushed against the space yeah
because because the earth is rolling
around this curve
is australia i hope it doesn't squash
you against the earth australia and
argentina are in trouble
okay uh
uh fellow that's a wall of text yeah but
let's uh it says motion changing
location he was trying to imitate my the
my uh definition
you can't use the word change to define
motion because change in motion are
synonyms
motion means change change means motion
there's synonyms you can't use the word
change we don't use it we're saying two
locations not change in location okay
that's the first clarification file
continue says are rotating objects
within your definition not in motion
okay i'm saying what is this guy
referring to
what would it mean for a perfectly
symmetrical object to change orientation
okay i can imagine a universe with just
two single piece
objects a triangle pointing face first
towards the cube the triangle is
rotating listen what he's saying he's
saying it's rotating it's in motion
right
about an axis that goes right through
the its face okay the minimum separation
between the two objects never changes
and yet anyone watching the movie would
qualitatively
determine that something is changing
frame to frame
now imagine a second triangle added to
this universe on the opposite side of
the cube also rotating rotating motion
right
but at a different rate than the first
okay
someone watching this movie can compare
the triangles to make a clock in their
mind a universe with time but no motion
we have a problem because the guy
already starting saying you know that
something is rotating
and so let me tell you what the issue is
with uh what this file is
suggesting okay let me show you this
here you have a little ball
let's assume it's a perfectly
symmetrical
uh ball made by god because he made it
out of a single piece it's not made of
atoms it's made out of a single piece
okay can you talk about the rotation of
this uh object
you can you just can't tell no you can't
i'm saying you can't because unless
unless you identify one point which i'm
going to show here there's your point
okay
there's your point
okay
now the only way i can know that this
single piece object rotates if i
identify a point and then yeah then move
it around okay then i can say okay now i
can say it's rotating oh we got a
problem uh-huh what is the problem
there's a difference between something
can or cannot rotate and i can or cannot
tell if it's rotating correct and uh and
that's what's my next point the point is
we're not talking about what i perceive
if the ball is rotating it does so
whether i'm alive or dead whether i'm
around or not so the ball knows it's
rotating in other words
okay i mean god knows but but right
my point here is the only way you're
going to know that a single piece
whatever in in this case a symmetric
object such as a ball can rotate right
is if you identify a point from a
conceptual point of view if you do not
identify one point you don't know if
it's rotating but the ball would know
because the ball knows that this point
is just here now is on the other side so
the ball knows it's rotating i don't
know because vermeer's a symmetrical
object and so the issue here is
what is the system that you're analyzing
are you analyzing the one piece ball
and you're saying it's rotating how do
you know it's rotating how does the ball
know it's rotating the only way is you
identify arbitrarily a point on its
surface and it's got to move around then
you know it's rotating and then you do
have motion because now
you know
no you have two locations of an object
right and you can talk about time only
if you compare that against some other
motion of that same ball could be you
know before and after for example you
take two arbitrary points you memorize
those points and you say i'm comparing
this one against that one now you have
time
okay so that's my question that's the
reason it was a little weirder can you
have a single piece uh cube
because then you can well you can
imagine okay so let's imagine so what
okay so you have a single piece
i feel like that's uh an impossibility
because with that you could tell the
corner from the edge
and then you could tell if it's rotating
even though it's single piece yeah and
again uh the issue is whether the cube
knows if it's rotating not if you know
if the cube is rotating we got to take
the observer away whether it's rotating
or not i guess
there there are no knowers it's rotating
correct yeah that's all it matters
the cube knows it's rotating
well but what i mean by that is uh you
know what we're saying he's rotating
because uh then people confuse it with
the observer and they say well do i know
if it's rotating you just clarify it is
rotating but you don't know it well yeah
you can make that assumption my point
here is that
even if i'm dead if i'm not around the
ball knows it's rotating if this point
right is now on the other side it knows
it's rotating or god or whoever but
i may not know because i watch and i say
well it's a single piece how do i know
it's rotating i don't because i don't
count the ball knows it's rotating
though well that's what we need that's
what people are confused that's where
people introduce the observer and there
are no observers in physics the ball
knows it's rotating that's physics even
the ball doesn't know there are no
numbers
well you don't need to know it how else
are you going to phrase that you don't
need to know her yeah we don't need a
number it's rotating don't worry about
it okay one issue that fella raised last
one here explain entropy bill
well entropy is with disorder that's all
it is and what is this order it's a uh
an opinion
uh it's uh you know it's a part of
religion
uh
does is the world becoming more ordered
or is it becoming less order well if you
ask the devil he says it's more ordered
if you ask god he says it's getting
screwed up you know i mean that was like
i like i like where it's going i like
these new
every you know evil is spread out evenly
i think that's uniformly is is it good
and god might say the opposite might say
oh my the squirrel is going to hell yeah
i mean yeah there's no
there's no objective measure for order
see uh it's the mathematicians who tried
to mathematize this thing called energy
and so they created this notion of
entropy we got a big debate on energy so
i'll be asking you about that later yeah
all they have to do is define energy and
if you can define it it's not an object
it's not a thing so you can't say you
transferred energy and so on and so
forth and and that's the issue also with
entropy entropy is a number that they
use in mathematics which has very little
to do with physics because it's just a
description are these mathematical
descriptions what are they used
it's got to do with uh you know the like
uh who was it uh brian green he explains
you know you have a glass
and uh because they're trying to explain
why there's a single direction to time
talking about time and they say you have
a glass you're drinking wine and the
glass falls on the floor it breaks
so what was ordered now suddenly becomes
disordered you can't put it back
together you can't put humpty dumpty
together again you know and and the
issue there is well is that ordered or
disordered i mean you might say it's
disordered well the devil might say the
opposite now it's order now that i broke
it you know you can't use it for
drinking
what does that mean because if you
change the scenario and the glass breaks
on top of one of those walls where you
want the glass broken
then it's ordered well again because you
wanted it to happen right what is orders
like saying what is beauty
well that's kind of like an opinion you
know what is beautiful to you is ugly to
me you know
i don't know what we learned
okay let's look at the questions uh what
people have today
yeah we're already there is it so let's
see what we have there
double sound echo echo
okay
a lot of echoes i hope we had it okay
then yeah yeah we had it okay uh when
are we gonna get rid of genders and
birth in labs
uh when test tube babies
the end of the world will take care of
that don't worry when humans are no more
because otherwise you know i think we're
gonna be playing around with genetics
for a while there's a genetic
engineering is one of the fields that
you could say is expanding or that
people are interested in because it's
like we don't have other jobs so what we
do around now is play around with
genetics but you know i mean
we do play around with it what does that
mean are we going to create humans in
test tubes from now on because women
don't want to have that big tummy now
anymore
i mean we discussed that as well yeah
weird stuff because you know you ask a
lot of the girls today especially the
guys as well but yeah primarily the
girls a lot of them don't want to have
kids and you know uh my my feeling on
that even though many women don't want
to admit it i think today i think has to
do with they don't want to they don't
want to go through the pain of labor
no labor pains
so i think it's got a lot to do with
that
someone asked about snow piercer which
is like a movie where
uh the rest of like an apocalypse
happened and all of humanity's on a
train and you got the rich people in the
front the poor people in the back eating
these like cockroach like slime things i
think that's what we were talking about
the cockroaches that are gonna take over
but you know if you ask people a lot of
people will say that it's the
insects it could be the cockroaches
whatever but the insects in general
which are going to survive but again i
asked the same question the
carboniferous had lots of it is famous
for insects and none of those insects
are around today today we have other
insects so somehow they died well they
disappeared i think the logic is i don't
see other animals so they have not
adapted to the world that we're in
whereas insects have adapted because we
see them everywhere you don't see you
know pumas and lions walking around
because we kind of got rid of them
they're kind of a bigger easier to
target and and get rid of but we're
still living with mosquitoes not because
we want to it's because they're they
have adapted to the the
environment so do they live forever is
the question well and i'm saying it's
it's it's more
if something comes after us then it's
probably the guys who have adapted to
who are everywhere basically yeah
the species that follow us will not be
tigers because they're already out of
the game
yeah something like that all i'm saying
is that all species even insects they
eventually die as well they die for yeah
but that's not the issue the issue is
who comes after us is gonna be
the ones that we it has to be from the
pool of those that we see it's either
gonna be true pigeons or cockroaches
that's all there are no pigeons i think
or
more dogs and cats because they're still
around that's crazy yeah we're gonna
take care of those as well uh are you
still here you're not up there with
bezos on a space station boss why aren't
you in
what space we got here
oh yeah and then we had a huge debate on
energy what is that what is energy what
is energy i'm asking you oh oh i don't
know what is energy energy is a is a
word
that's all it is and nobody can define
energy it's like yeah energy is an
imagination no no
we have uh richard feynman and he said
it perfectly he says you know none of us
knows what energy is and that's a
perfect way of defining energy nobody
has everybody likes to use it because
it's the word like the word spirit
and of traditional religion they use the
word spirit for everything it feels like
a real thing yeah and we know we get
zapped when we touch the the outlets so
there's something there we call that
energy i don't know what it is but it's
doing something yeah it's that i don't
know what yeah that's that's that's what
it is
[Laughter]
huge debate on energy
i thought you could uh help us on the
debate on energy yeah i'm saying it's
it's a concept that no one has def i
define it as a synonym of spirit
so whenever you say energy you're saying
spirit because you have no idea what
you're talking about when you say energy
it's a number that the mathematicians
put in an equation that's all it is
because it's kind of like a catch-all
they use yeah they use it for
electricity they use it for heat but
they're using they use the word field
also the word field is used every two
seconds nobody knows what a field is
when you look it up it's it's just a
bunch of numbers that's all field is
there is no physical object called field
there is no physical object called
energy but they transfer energy and they
stretch the field we got foot energy
equals walking yeah is that correct uh
energy is change over time
yeah
whatever that is uh change is what uh so
if assuming that's change over time what
are you talking can you say you
transferred change over time i
transferred
change over how do you transfer change
if it's a concept you know you can't you
can't imagine change you can just
imagine the objects which are changing
yeah people talk about transferring
energy transferring information how do
you transfer information how do you
transfer a verb a concept
see this we know we know what we mean
but when you get down to the brass text
you're not really transferring
information yeah what are you
transferring oh you're not changing
you've got to figure out whether you're
changing light on us on a on a computer
tops well it's like saying when gravity
warps time what did you transfer how did
gravity do that magic trick of warping
time when you have two concepts you
gotta identify the objects in that
invisible world that's the only way
you're gonna figure it out well again
there's so much uh i mean the way a
language is built it's just chock full
of metaphor i mean even when you speak
even when we're speaking uh
scientifically you bring up god a lot
but it's more that metaphorical you know
you know it's not like if we spoke like
the i think it's the klingons who are
perfectly logical i might be wrong about
that i know i know there's a race in
star trek the the the guy who yeah um
what's his name there's also one why is
it like an android but there's also one
in um
it's called guardians of the galaxy he
also speaks perfectly literal and if we
spoke like that all the time i'm pretty
sure
a lot of things would fall away poetry
religion uh any any uh pseudoscience
would fall away because if you're
speaking completely literal then you
have to know what you're talking about
yeah and that's what
mathematical physics don't know what
they're talking about yeah because if
you could
sprinkle in some metaphor and poetry you
can get away with murder yeah and what
i'm saying there's nothing wrong with
using poetry especially if you use it as
a closing argument no problem you want
to summarize something that's okay but
the
theory
it better be literal that one in physics
has got to be literal that's what i love
about programming you have to be literal
yeah there's no you can't doesn't let
you
you can't you know what you mean but the
program's like no this is what you said
what else you got there
spock that might be the one oh i know
that's the guy but i don't know what his
race is he might be a cyborg or a robot
i think it's a spot yeah i'm not sure he
is
that's it
okay folks then we'll see you next time
and same time same station oh but i
won't be here
yeah uh he's on a secret mission he's on
a secret mission it's secret that's why
we can't tell what the mission is okay
so
okay